Now recall, we have looked at Image
Warping, which basically is an attempt
of trying to figure out how to
transform one image to the other,
which actually says that maybe now
we should be looking at as a way of
actually doing a warping from Projection
Plane 1 to Projection Plane 2.
Of course, we had looked at things
like translating an image, scaling, or
Euclidean things like rotation,
which includes full translation and
rotating the image.
But, we also looked at
things like rotation and
affine projective types of things.
If you recall, translation basically
required us to model two unknowns.
Euclidean, which basically had
the true translations when one
rotation had three unknowns,
affine, which I counted from.
I had six unknowns and
projective had eight unknowns.